plus you'd also have to convert to
Christianity probably learn how to speak
German and do everything by hand and
it's obviously an incredible it's reckon
dear Deutsch Abba assassin is so good CC
ambition look at I'm basically an Amish
this is an amazing life I'll leave my
family for this what up guys welcome to
the just pearly things YouTube channel
and welcome to my reaction series before
I start don't forget to subscribe to the
channel and ring that notification Bell
the way you're going to be notified of
my daily videos like the video on your
way in let's get started so today I am
going to be reacting to a mgtow channel
um this is called Sandman and you know I
I really do think the mgtow guys get a
bad rap like everyone says oh they can't
get women anyway but honestly the
majority of mgtow guys that I've covered
really they they were married they did
have success the women just like ruined
them you know so then they're like I'm
not gonna do this so it's really
interesting to get their point of view
so um let's pull up the clip this one's
about Amish women now for those of you
that don't know Amish is a type of woman
they don't have any technology so it's
I'm actually really interested to see
what they have to say because my
hypothesis is that Amish women are a
little bit better than because they're
not brainwashed by social media hi
everyone Sandman here today's video is
brought to you by donation from Peter
and he said that he was just sending me
an extra donation so I decided to make
this video so I'll dedicate this video
to him as well today I came back from a
working vacation in the United States I
was out doing a test run for a new
YouTube channel that's all about
traveling your own way and while I was
down there in Pennsylvania I
unexpectedly found myself in the heart
of Amish country and at one point I was
actually stuck behind a traffic jam of
roughly six to seven horse-drawn
carriages all attempting to make a right
turn it was one of the most surreal
experiences that I've had in a really
long time and I immediately started
observing the way that both May male and
female Amish relate to one another and
started to research how their society
works and also all the photos that you
see in this video except for the one
with the three girls I actually took
myself anyways I immediately noticed
that the men and women that I saw didn't
seem to mix and match all that much and
another shocking thing I saw was that
many of the women also went Barefoot
talk about a society where women are
literally both barefoot and pregnant I
went online and found out that their
divorce rate is approaching zero percent
and for the most wow that's so crazy
when you get rid of Technology we stay
with our men wow wow that is crazy zero
percent wow part they're a close society
and even if you wanted to leave it it
would be difficult if not impossible
because you'd actually have to learn how
to use technology and get an education
as most Amish people are only educated
to the eighth grade level
if you take a woman's choices away or
make her choices extremely hard to make
in the first place then the vast
majority of women will stay where they
are in life and settle for it sure there
are some women that'll leave the Amish
lifestyle behind but they also have to
leave their family friends as well as
the way of life and cultural identity
behind to do so but I don't want to talk
about the religious reasons why the
Amish do what they do instead I want to
focus on the cultural stuff as a western
culture and civilization we've let our
women run amok and as I explored Amish
Country in Pennsylvania it showed me the
prime example of how the most ideal form
of traditionalism works and it's a form
of traditionalism where most women have
six or seven children they also wear
zero makeup beauty products and look
absolutely plain and you can't see any
body curves because of their dresses and
instead just focus on their unpainted
faces on my way back to Canada I went
into a McDonald's somewhere in
Pennsylvania to get an iced coffee and I
ran into a Mennonite group and started a
conversation with them Mennonites are
very similar to the Amish but they still
believe in using some form forms of
technology they were on their way to
Canada to visit relatives and there were
six of them three men and three women
and this is my first time in my entire
life that I saw three women out in
public with no makeup on for pretty much
the first time in my life I realized how
boring oh my God I do that all the time
is that not normal did not wear makeup
look at this is why all these chicks
will be dogging on me saying I look old
ugly whatever but I'm like I don't even
know what these look like like I
genuinely I can't I've never even seen
your face there's like a pound of makeup
it's painted on it's like you don't want
to scare a man like what do you look
like in the morning chick take her to
the pool after they say take her to a
pool I will say growing up we would buy
furniture from the almond and they're a
very happy group of people I thought
they were kind of crazy at the time
because they were talking about evil
technology was but you know the older I
get the more I'm like you know maybe
maybe there's something to that I don't
know plain mostly what makeup has become
so normalized that you'd find people on
Twitter and on the end internet arguing
that like when you show
um before and after picks you'll find
women actually arguing that the women
still look the same when they clearly
don't like but it's so normalized that
it's almost like women can't even see
the difference anymore no it's true it's
like we live in this delusion where we
like it's so weird because everything
like is geared toward us living in
delusion and not reality so it's like we
put on all this makeup and now we look
hotter and now we get to believe that we
are hotter than and then we put on this
Botox and like now we don't get to live
in this reality that we are older than
we where I just like I don't know I just
kind of I've always felt like you should
just kind of get what you get you know
what I'm like I I don't I feel like if
you get a guy but you have all this
makeup and like fake like you
didn't really now you gotta paint your
space on for a lifetime it just seems
like long I think the equivalent of
makeup bpls and all these things that
women do is like a guy like renting an
apartment like renting a a sports car
like buying clothes that he can't afford
just to put up this facade of him being
successful I think that's the same thing
look when they simply have no makeup
jewelry or other sexually accentuating
or revealing clothing I saw how little
physical appeal women have if they don't
enhance their beauty first they
typically look more plain than your
grandmother so I don't want any of you
to worry about me going off and running
off to become an Amish and if anyone out
there listening to this is thinking
about it forget about it the Amish
actually share a gene pool that comes
from roughly 200 people that originally
came from Germany so basically your kids
would be swimming in the shallow end of
the gene pool plus you'd also have to
convert to Christianity probably learn
how to speak German and do everything by
hand and it's obviously an incredible
especond dear Deutsche is
look it I'm basically an Amish chick I'm
German guys I could join I could join
tough life if you don't have electricity
for lighting and gasoline for
transportation but I did see many Amish
homes equipped I don't think they are
accepting YouTubers though dang it you
know yeah I don't know how well I would
do without electricity I think I would I
would definitely struggle on the farm
you know at least I admit it do you know
what I'm tired of I'm tired of these
these chicks like I just I try my best
okay I'm not I'm still a woman all right
so let's not act like I'm you know but I
try my best to just like live in reality
like this is reality but women just like
live in this delusional world that isn't
real and like on Twitter I'll see these
women that live in an apartment in a
major city talking about how to they
want to marry a farmer and they just
want to live on a plot of land and live
off the land do you realize that you
could like still do that now like I know
we're in modern times but I've met women
like like that a bit because my family
would travel every summer we'd go on
like a vacation or whatever and on
vacation
um we would meet like um these women
that worked on like like the one that's
coming to my hat is like a dog Farm
where like she was like working at like
it was they had like sled dogs it was in
Alaska like you can get jobs where
you're really working in nature but they
don't get these jobs and I'm like I'm
just observing here but I I think that
if you've spent your whole life not
doing farm work I I don't think the
reality of farm work is gonna be what
you think and I know this because I've
done a little bit minimal let's not put
me as a farmer's don't don't do that see
like the delusional women would say I'm
now a farmer no I'm not but I did have
chickens when I was younger I had pet
chickens and I had pet dog and let me
tell you there's a lot of you gotta
deal with literally you have to Scoop
the Poop you gotta feed them and also if
the coyotes get into your like um your
farmer thingy like the the chicken coop
you gotta literally like pick up the
guts it's really disgusting like it's
horrible you just wake up one day all
your chickens are dead
and you're like I would always run to my
dad I'd be like Dad no the coyotes got
him again then your dad runs into the
field with his gun trying to shoot the
coyote you can't find it he kills a
bunch of your chick it's like a hole and
then sometimes they get him during the
day it's yeah anyways my whole point is
this I don't think it's like what they
think and I just get really tired of
this like delusion Oh I wanna I wanna
farmer man well why don't you be a
farmer wife first oh oh we can't do that
go Scoop the Poop go go ahead and it's
funny because in the 1800s this was
expected from women like you know how
they say like do all this so you can get
a wife it used to be serve your husband
so you'd have to learn these skills to
serve your husband and bring stuff to
the table not so he could get you and be
like so you could get him but I don't
know modern society has just like warped
it around where we live in this delusion
that we don't need men we live in this
delusion that we want to be farmer
chicks and it's just all delusional and
I don't like it it just irritates me I
just like to live in reality propane
tanks for home heating so from what I
gather they seem to believe in the use
of fossil fuels I also saw many of the
young people wearing sunglasses I
couldn't figure out why but many of them
had them on I can only imagine what
Amish men are told about with regards to
Western women to be honest I think the
moment they hear about how high our
divorce rates are as well as how English
men get ruined they probably laugh to
themselves all about it and I can only
imagine how they feel when they see our
women destroying our culture there are
probably very few reasons for men to
want to leave that culture the Amish one
behind and I wonder to what degree
gynocentrism functions in such places
the women obviously can't divorce the
men or it's made very difficult for them
to do so and it's hard for her to run
off with another guy her children and
chores often keep her busy all the time
and it's extremely difficult for her to
leave as I say this this becomes the
perfect segue for the Amish rite of
passage known as Rumspringa this is
supposedly when Teenage and young Amish
run off and take drugs and experiment
with other cultures but apparently this
doesn't happen as much as the media
wants us to believe and in the end
almost 90 percent of Amish teenagers
choose to be baptized and join the Amish
Church I'd also be interested to know if
more women than men leave the Amish when
they become teenagers my guess was you
did Anonymous check what if she left her
whole like Community for you possibly so
I'm like I feel like an Amish chick
would be like a hot commodity because
they know like all the cooking all the
cleaning they can do all this
because the reality and they're they're
probably pretty pure think about it like
this like I'm not going to follow the
woman so she has to follow me yeah but I
was thinking like that's probably why
they run off more than the men oh yeah
because they're like a hot commodity
they're thin they they believe in all
the submitted like they got they were
like like a valley they could be a value
ad and they're like I don't have to do
farm work all I have to do is like cook
with a Roomba wow this is an amazing
life I'll leave my family for this that
more women would leave because they can
more easily integrate into our society
because it's easier for them to find a
beta male provider ready to give them
that new lifestyle there you go there
you go world if that's actually the case
then there could easily be more men in
the Amish community than women leading
to the value of women going up in that
Society so that could still mean that
the bottom 10 to 20 percent of their
male population could be left without
wives I'm not sure if that's the case or
not but it would be certain very
interesting to figure it out I've also
included a link in the description below
I want to visit an Amish community if
you guys know any Amish communities I
can visit I've been wanting to do this
video for a while I think it'd be so
interesting to like interview them and
like talk about their culture so if you
guys know any Amish in either Europe or
the us feel free go to something called
women's lib would have a field day among
the Amish and it's from the book called
Rumspringa to be or not to be Amish and
here's what it says Davey says that
women's lib would have a field day among
the Amish in certain senses Amish women
are almost more esteemed than men he
explains in the Amish culture women are
more important more valuable than men
because they raise the children who are
the future of the Amish sect and they
maintain the home which is the locus of
Amish life however the collective
portrait of women in Amish society that
emerges from interviews with Amish men
women boys and girls is similar to that
of the pages of family life women is the
objects of a reflexively misogynistic
culture which treats them as weak dumb
and in need of protection from the world
that's what the book has to say but
that's also kind of a trick women rule
but are still treated as weak and feeble
that's how powerful gynocentrism is in
our species as a whole in a traditional
Society like the Amish women appear to
have no power yet at the same time they
actually do of course women and girls
from that culture are going to say that
they have no power and of course men and
boys from that culture are going to say
that women have no power as well that's
the dynamic in our species that makes
our two Sexes tolerate each other most
men believe they have power over
Humanity but we don't actually have it
women know that they have power over our
species but they pretend like they don't
this obviously satisfies the male ego
because it makes him feel in charge and
easily parted with his resources Because
he believes he can produce virtually
Limitless quantities of goods and women
in general know that they have all the
power and typically laugh at men and how
gullible we become when a beautiful
woman walks into the room the religion
that most men worship is the illusion of
male power most men believe they have
absolute power over women in the world
and it's their own guided faith in
ourselves that leads us into this deep
trouble with the opposite sex it's the
illusion that we're in control but when
we take the red pill we become aware
that we once worshiped ourselves as
better than women but now we realize
that we're actually better and can
finally act out on our own best
interests as men going our own way our
best choice is not to get involved in
relationships at all and it's really
upsetting women out there that men are
starting to use women's techniques
instead of actually following the
scripted behaviors that we always seem
to follow in the past we don't seem to
fall for their dirty tricks anymore and
we understand that we have all the power
when we aren't going to hand it over to
them for free all right it's so funny
when guys start to get red pilled and
start like you start to see them
stopping like letting their wives
mothers whoever the hell is bitching at
them control them but the women the
women get very mad at this it's like
almost like a kid like when you tell a
kid no they'll have like a temper when
they realize oh my God I have zero
control my parent is going to do is not
gonna like appease my wishes yeah um I
have a theory I think it's almost
impossible for a man to even become red
pill or to like realize his until he can
stand up to his mother until a man can
actually stand up to his mother he's
never going to be able to stand up to
women have you heard Jesse uh lee
Peterson he talks about he's like
forgive your mother it's really
interesting and he'll be like um he his
whole view is like you can't you have to
like uh or apologize to your they have
to forgive your mom and apologize to
your mom for resenting her that's what
he says and then forgive your father for
not protecting you from her that's like
the funny I don't even mean it's in a
bad way because I when I say stand up to
your mother I don't even mean like in a
bad way I mean more like because women
have this thing especially mothers and
their sons where they always want to
tell their sons how to be yeah but at
some point a man has to realize that
he's the only one that can chat his way
forward in life at that point once a man
gets to that point your mom is still
always going to want to still give you
advice in quotes so a lot of the times
the advice she's giving you is not
really useful to you in terms of the way
you need to to navigate the world as a
man so until men realize that and
realize that okay you can listen to your
mom and make her feel good but when you
move out in the world you have to do
what a man has to do and not take a lot
of the things she says like just take
the things she says with a grain of salt
but I mean a lot of men never get to
that point yeah and then they just get
controlled by their wives instead and
that's probably why the wives and the
mom fight because they're both to
control the Sun
they're like no he has to listen to me
now he has to listen to me
just delusion e we finally understand
that our place in the sexual Marketplace
is much higher than theirs most women
are just gold-plated K cars they look
like they're quality and expensive on
the outside but eventually the gold
flakes off of them like a 50 year old
Oscar statue from the Academy Awards
after my experience in Amish Country I
now realize that the tragedy of modern
Western women is not that women will not
know what it truly feels like to be a
man which they desperately seek to
become for some strange reason but
instead the real tragedy is that they
will never know what it's like to be
either a man or a woman instead they
will be some sort of chemically spayed
woman child pouting her lips on a selfie
stick trying desperately to get male
attention over the internet but at least
the Amish women push out half a dozen
children and nurture them into adulthood
they become mothers and at least the
Amish men are masculine and hard-working
and accomplish things using their hands
most Amish also own their own land and
it's debt free and paid off so even in
an Amish Society if a woman leaves to be
with an outsider she would most likely
have to make a financial sacrifice she
would be sacrificing the finance
security of marrying into her culture
and to be with a man that would almost
certainly be able to afford his own
property both free and clear but if she
ended up with a man outside her culture
she would be able to divert his assets
and labor for her own ends I think that
the main reason that Civilization Rose
in the first place was because
patriarchy put a muzzle on the desires
of women ever since patriarchy started
declining in Western societies so is our
culture another thing I noticed about
the Amish is it looks like a red pill
moment when I was like patriarchy is a
good thing because when men get power
their benevolent dictators like they're
not they're not these evil abusers that
the feminists like paint them out to be
they're actually like they gave us
everything we wanted think about that
the men had all the power and they gave
us power like because men just have this
natural instinct to protect women and
give us what we want so it's like when
women get the power to vote it's like we
almost have double the power because we
have our own voting power and then we
also have the power that like we know
that we have over men so it's almost
it's almost like more power than men but
when women get power we clearly abuse
men and we like we basically make it so
women can do anything and have no
conflict that that's what we do legally
where men are actually more like
benevolent dictators and patriarchy is
actually a good thing seem to be
traveling in groups and never alone it
kind of reminded me of the Mormon guys
with the name tags walking around
together to help each other or get away
from Temptation anyways I believe that
the Amish culture is safe from Western
influence if Western culture hasn't
destroyed it up until now then it
probably won't I also noticed that there
was no epidemic of obesity in the Amish
community and many of the women I saw in
their 20s didn't seem to have an ounce
of fat on their bodies and neither did
the man I want to end this video by
saying that most men including myself
probably don't want to go back to
traditionalism but at the same time we
also don't want the status quo I
certainly don't want to live without
electricity also known as the
transportation of manual labor from one
point to another using copper wires
anyways that's all I've got to say for
today I seriously want to visit an army
this community I have always wanted to
do this because I swear when I was
younger I thought it was so I mean I was
like how do they live but but I thought
it was so interesting because they were
such happy kids like I remember they
also had so much energy like they were
literally running around like when we
would go get the furniture and if you
watch like a day in the life of the
Amish it's so crazy all that they do in
a day like I'm like I do not do that
much um but let me know what you guys
think in the comments um like the video
on your way out and subscribe to the
channel should we go back to being Amish
is that the solution take away
everything lights out power out Amish
let me know and subscribe to the channel
I'll talk to you next time